nice to see you nice to see you too you
know I may not be from Texas but my dad
actually is oh really so there we go do
you know he's from uh Johnson County
what what are you
dead serious I'm from Johnson and Taryn
really yeah I lived in both growing up
yeah so I didn't really know my father
very much okay me neither
but I do know that's where he's from
yeah exactly that's where I am right now
this is therapy this is therapy welcome
to my couch yeah I can talk a lot about
that issue um but no but you had a mini
Dawson's Creek Union with Michelle right
Oscars how is that like when you run
into each other like yes okay I'm still
excited still very excited it's 20 years
though that's a crazy amount of time oh
25 yeah wow over 20 years it was a
little bit less than a year she was
saying I can't believe you're a father
no but that's what's so cool like years
later you knew each other so young yeah
and like you were the kids yeah yeah
it's I mean this we don't get to see
each other all that often she has her
kids she lives in New York I have my kid
we live here but that was a lovely night
and just having the opportunity to see
her I hadn't met her new husband since
they got together oh yeah who's the
third person in that photograph yeah so
yeah I mean it's a funny thing to get
like the most fancy dress-up party that
you can possibly do and then have a high
school reunion but that's what we did
yeah I love that though it's fun
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]